vous êtes sur rtl
pour rtl matin à vie qui vous convient
il est 7 heures 44 excellente journée à
vous tous qui nous écoutait alba ventura
vous recevez ce matin françois bayrou le
président du modem bonjour françois
bayrou bonjour emmanuel macron 54%
marine le pen 46% c'est le résultat de
notre sondage bva orange rtl ce matin
vous dites que c'est en bonne voie pour
le second tour alors moi je ne suis
jamais rassuré et jamais rassurant
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un deuxième tour
d'élection présidentielle
n'importe quoi peut se produire on est
dans une dans un espace de temps
exactement comme dans la tragédie
grecque oui il se passe des choses à la
dimension des siècles en quelques
minutes il peut arriver n'importe quel
accident n'importe quel coup de théâtre
mais ce qui est non pas rassurant mais
d'une certaine manière pour la
démocratie française c'est un c'est un
point positif c'est que les électeurs
sont en train de remettre les choses à
leur place l'italien c'est à dire
qu'elles sont le les deux avenirs
proposé par les deux candidats il se
trouve que ce dernier jour vous avez vu
le la montée de l'inquiétude à propos de
la candidate du rassemblement national
les gens les français mesurent ce que
signifierait son élection alors on prend
deux ou trois choses très très simple la
première de ces choses c'est marine le
pen propose que pour la france
poutine la russie de poutine devienne
son allié militaire
encore le 31 mars c'est à dire en plein
milieu du drame qui est en train de se
jouer en ukraine
proposé à la france qui est à la tête de
l'union européenne qui est un des pays
de l'alliance atlantique de l'alliance
des pays de liberté lui proposer de
changer d'alliance pour aller rechercher
du côté de de l'agresseur sans précédent
c'est c'est inimaginable deuxième chose
elle propose qu'on rompe un certain
nombre de nos coopérations essentiel
avec l'allemagne depuis combien de
décennies on n'a pas entendu en france
quelqu'un présenté l'allemagne comme
étant
en situation
de de nous gêner et que donc il faudrait
rompre avec ce pays et le nôtre qui est
notre frère je prends un exemple très
simple airbus qu'est ce que c'est airbus
et la france et l'allemagne alors on
propose de sortir
de cet accord
à la dimension de ce demi siècle et vous
savez fait le plus grand succès
industriels touchés 30 et raisonnable
d'arrêter aussi sur la mesure d'
emmanuel macron sur la retraite à 64 ou
65 ans il ne parle pas forcément de
l'allemagne où il ne parle pas forcément
des alliances internationales mais ils
disent cette retraite à 65 ans c'est pas
pour nous c'est une mauvaise idée vous
même avez dit que l'annoncent avait été
brutale oui parce que parce que la
présentation a été
décalé par rapport à la réalité de quoi
s'agit-il c'est très très simple tout le
monde le sait comme on vit plus vieux et
qui a de moins en moins de gens qui
travaillent dans une société comme la
nôtre le déséquilibre s'établit entre
les contributeurs et les pensionnés et
la pension comme vous savez c'est le
système français qui s'appelle par
répartition ça veut dire par répartition
c'est très simple c'est ceux qui
travaillent qui chaque mois assure le
revenu de ceux qui sont à la retraite
s'il y en a moins qui travaillent par
rapport au nombre de ceux qui sont à la
retraite il ya un
résultat très simple les pensions de
retraite ce que chacun des retraités
touchent à la fin du mois baissent donc
vous
je la défends avec deux précautions
essentielles la première de ces
précautions c'est on doit tenir compte
toujours et en priorité de ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tous tout au long
de leur vie les carrières longues comme
on dit et on doit tenir compte de la
pénibilité
je suis naturellement comme maire de pau
à la tête d'un ccas comme on dit de
l'action sociale de la ville je sais
très bien ce que la vie des femmes c'est
souvent des femmes qui travaillent pour
aller s'occuper des personnes âgées pour
l'élever et quelquefois elles sont
lourdes et quelquefois c'est un travail
très difficile tout le monde ne prétend
à elle seule elle se fonde ma lingots
d'or à 104 ans donc pénibilité les deux
choses carrières longues et pénibilité
et enfin troisièmement il faut que ça se
fasse progressivement et je pense qu'on
peut beaucoup amélioré la progressivité
on peut avoir un allongement qui soit un
allongement volontaire
il ya beaucoup de gens qui
souhaiteraient travailler et on peut
inciter à cet allongement volontaire et
vous voyez que ce que je décris c'est en
réalité une méthode pour que le nouveau
gouvernement le nouveau parlement
prépare cette réforme glee manière c'est
que
non seulement je pense mais je crois
vous avez souvent dit il ya une volonté
de faire sécession de la part d'une
partie du pays une envie de révolte
alors cette envie de révolte on l'a vu
au pour résultats du premier tour 45 %
pour le vote protestataire incarnée par
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon en
2007 françois bayrou c'est vous qui
occupait la troisième place c'était le
vote modéré que s'est il passé en quinze
ans ben peut-être que en 2007 on avait
construit un mouvement qui était un
mouvement de renouvellement profond avec
un grand succès comme vous souvenez en
tout cas une grande audience parmi les
électeurs et je vous rappelle que dans
cette élection on avait fait baisser le
vote extrémiste on était trois en
réalité sarkozy ségolène royal et moi on
avait fait baisser le vote le pen à 10%
c'est la seule fois où y est eu une
chute de ce vote extrémiste mais au
physique aussi des sujets règle il faut
oui plein
dans la vie la vie d'un pays et parfois
la vie d'une personne ou d'une famille
il toujours des sujets qui ne sont pas
réglés mais il ya une chose essentielle
il faut que vous soyez que nous soyons
porteur d'espoir force est encore
possible ça c'est un fils franchement
non seulement c'est encore possible mais
c'est nécessaire donc y'a même pas à
s'interroger la seule question c'est
quel chemin suivre je vais vous dire ce
que je crois profondément
il ne peut pas y avoir de politique sans
idéal si vous ne portez pas quelque
chose qui permette à chacun des citoyens
de sortir de son cadre de vie habituel
et de se projeter dans l'avenir
alors vous êtes en défaut vous fait pas
ce qu'il faut oui mais je repars de la
retraite à 65 ans pour certains c'est
pas un idéal
mais je viens de vous dire on ne peut
pas accepter que les retraites baisse
c'est ça c'est c'est simple le les
millions de nos compatriotes qui ont en
effet accéder à ce moment de la vie que
beaucoup considèrent comme positif pour
eux on ne peut pas accepter que leurs
revenus baissent et donc c'est évident
qu'il faut équilibrer mais il faut le
faire de manière progressive
emmanuel macron a dit à peu près en dix
ans d'ici 2030 et je trouve que c'est
légitime que le futur gouvernement et le
futur parlement prenne ça en main parce
que
dernière phrase le quinquennat ne
s'achève pas le soir du 24 avril il
commence et tout sauf démocratique
majorité gouvernement les forces
politiques différentes qui vont
dialoguer ensemble ont la responsabilité
de trouver cet équilibre emmanuel macron
indien il faut inventer quelque chose de
nouveau pour rassembler toutes les
sensibilités afin de bâtir une action
commune au service de notre nation c'est
donc un nouveau parti c'est ça qu'il
propose éventuellement pour la suite il
ya deux questions alors on va on va les
traiter en assurant une phrase chacune
on a besoin de deux choses on a besoin
d'une organisation de toutes les forces
de ce grand espace du centre que j'ai
plaidé défendu toute ma vie et donc
première première show une organisation
deuxième chose on a besoin de pluralisme
on a besoin que chacun retrouve son
identité dans cet ensemble son identité
son histoire ses valeurs comme on dit ce
qu'il a apporté et il faut que chacun
soit respecté en tant que telle ethnie
quand même à nous étonne une nouvelle
organisation
je pas si c'est à partir une
organisation et une organisation
unitaire le plus unitaire possible à
condition que chacun soit respecté dans
ce qu'il est vous voyez que c'est pas si
difficile en tout cas de poser les
principes de questions courtes réponses
courtes le soutien de françois hollande
après celui nicolas sarkozy ça fait la
différence à à votre avis je sais pas si
ça fait la différence mais il ya une
chose qui est évidente il n'y a pas un
responsable en france aujourd'hui qui
puisse appeler à voter pour l'extrême
droite
pour une raison simple
je ne connais pas un seul pays dans le
monde ni un seul pays dans l'histoire
dans lequel les
solutions où les politiques extrémistes
ont apporté du bonheur ou du bien-être
aucun aucun ni le portugal de salazar
n'est l'espagne de franco ni l'italie de
mussolini ni pire encore ce qui s'est
passé dans l'allemagne hitlérienne qui
peut prétendre qu'un seul des citoyens
de ces pays se soit porté rapidement
françois bayrou qu'est-ce que vous
inspirent ces quelques centaines
d'étudiants qui manifestent parce que la
fiche présidentielle c'est-à-dire en
résultat démocratique ne leur plaît pas
mais bon il ya dans dans les générations
régulièrement une sorte de révolte ou de
réticence ou d'exaspération par rapport
aux situations de l'art du monde dans
lequel on vit d'un côté c'est bien et de
l'autre il ya aussi un leurre dans tout
ça parce que ça et ça laisse effet
peut-être pour les empêcher de s'engager
merci beaucoup français merci à vous et
l'intégralité de l'entretien comme
chaque jour